AND NOW ALSO NEW YORK, TO
SEAN HANNITY RIGHT NOW.
>> Sean: TUCKER, THANK YOU.
GRATIAN WAS AS ALWAYS.
WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
TONIGHT, THERE IS A CLEAR FRONT
RUNNER IN THE EXTREME RADICAL
DEMOCRATIC SOCIALIST PARTY, AND,
YEP, THAT IS A 78-YEAR-OLD
CURMUDGEON, DEVOUT SOVIET-STYLE
SOCIALIST.
YOU KNOW, THE GUY THAT TOOK A
HONEYMOON IN THE FORMER
SOVIET UNION, THAT GUY.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS IN A
STATE OF ROOST TONIGHT.
THE MODERATES -- THEY ARE
NONEXISTENT, LONG GONE,
PRAGMATIC, CENTRIST POLITICIANS.
THERE IS NOT EVEN ROOM FOR JOE
LIEBERMAN ANY LONGER IN THIS
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
SO RADICAL, EXTREME, AND, YES,
SOCIALISM THAT WOULD DESTROY THE
GREAT AMERICAN PROSPERITY THAT
WE NOW EXPERIENCE OVER THE LAST
THREE YEARS.
LAST NIGHT, BERNIE SANDERS,
BERNIE SANDERS, HUGE VICTORY IN
NEW HAMPSHIRE.
NOW ACCORDING TO BRAND-NEW
POLLS, BERNIE SANDERS IS LEADING
THE DEMOCRATIC FIELD WITH A
MASSIVE EDGE HEADED INTO SUPER
TUESDAY STATES.
NOW THERE WAS NO OTHER WAY TO
PUT THIS.
IF THIS GUY IS ELECTED -- ARE
PRETTY MUCH, THEY ARE ALL JUST
VARIATIONS OF HIM -- THESE
POLICIES WOULD DESTROY THE
ECONOMY OF THIS COUNTRY.
LET’S SEE, A $94 TRILLION NEW
GREEN DEAL IN TEN YEARS BUT WE
ONLY TAKEN FOUR, FOUR AND A HALF
TRILLION.
IN THE SAME TENURE.
MATT, 52
TRILLION DOLLARS, MEDICARE FOR
ALL.
THE GOVERNMENT, LITERALLY,
SOCIALISM.
THEY WOULD CONTROL THE MEANS OF
PRODUCTION FOR THOUSANDS OF
BUSINESSES ACROSS AMERICA.
OH, AND TAKE OVER THE ENERGY
SECTOR FOR THE FIRST TIME IN 75
YEARS.
WE ARE ENERGY INDEPENDENT.
TAXES FOR EVERY AMERICAN -- HE
IS RUNNING ON THIS PLATFORM.
WE ARE GOING TO RAISE OUR TAXES.
MAYBE DOUBLE OR TRIPLE THEM.
AND IF YOU SAVED ENOUGH MONEY
AFTER WE TAX TO THE FIRST TIME,
WE WILL LEGALIZE STEALING MORE O
IT.
AFTER YOU DIE, YOU WILL GIVE US
ANOTHER CHUNK OF YOUR MONEY.
OH, AND WE WILL LOSE JOBS
BECAUSE OF HIS EXTREME
ENVIRONMENTAL POLICIES.
THAT IS A PLATFORM.
YOUR BANK ACCOUNTS WILL BE
STOPPED WITH A WEALTH TAX BY THE
IRS MIGHT CONFISCATE ANY INCOME
OVER A CERTAIN UNDISCLOSED
AMOUNT.
BERNIE IS STANDING BY THE IDEA
OF MAXIMUM INCOME.
OKAY.
IF YOU EARN IT IN THREE MONTHS,
WHY WOULD YOU BOTHER WORKING
ANOTHER DAY OF THE YEAR?
CREATING JOBS FOR OTHER
AMERICANS?
OR AT LEAST, THAT IS WHAT HE HAS
SAID PUBLICLY.
THAT IS WHAT HE IS ADVOCATED FOR
AND STANDING LIFE.
BY ALL ACCOUNTS, EVEN SOME
DEMOCRATS, PROMINENT DEMOCRATS,
SEE THIS AS A DISASTER FOR THEIR
PARTY.
LOOK AT THIS NEW MONMOUTH
UNIVERSITY POLL, ROUGHLY
TWO-THIRDS OF VOTERS BELIEVE
PRESIDENT TRUMP WILL BE
REELECTED.
ME, I AM IRISH, I ALWAYS THINK
SOMETHING BAD IS GOING TO HAPPEN
AT ANY SECOND.
YOU KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS?
DON’T COUNT ON IT.
THE ONLY WAY YOU GET THERE IS IF
YOU SHOW UP AND VOTE IN 266
DAYS.
NEW GALLUP POLL SHOWING 53% OF
AMERICANS WOULD NOT VOTE FOR A
SOCIALIST PARADE WHY THAT’S NOT
99%, I DON’T KNOW.
NOT EXACTLY CAUSE FOR
CELEBRATION.
THAT MEANS WE HAVE A FIGHT ON
OUR HANDS IN TERMS OF THE FUTURE
AND DIRECTION OF THE COUNTRY.
43% OF AMERICANS WOULD VOTE FOR
A SOCIALIST WAY THAT IS PRETTY
SCARY.
YOU CAN’T TAKE ANYTHING FOR
GRANTED.
ULTIMATELY, THE ONLY POLL THAT
WILL MATTER -- AS I SAID, AND
265 DAYS, AND ANYTHING IS
POSSIBLE.
FOR EXAMPLE, LOOK AT QUID AND
PRO" AND JOE AND SIRI EXPERIENCE
HUNTER.
JOE THOUGHT HE WAS GOING TO
WALTZ RIGHT INTO THE DEMOCRATIC
NOMINATION WRITING ON
BARACK OBAMA’S COACH FILLS THE
ENTIRE WAY.
OH, THEY DID GIVE US 13 MILLION
MORE AMERICANS ON FOOD STAMPS,
8 MILLION MORE PROPERTY, THE
LOWEST LABEL PARTICIPATION RATES
AND SEE ’70s.
THE OUTCOME A GREAT RECORD.
THEY GIVE THE MULLAHS IN IRAN
$150 BILLION IN CASH AND OTHER
CURRENCIES, AS THEY CHANT DEATH
TO AMERICA.
WOW.
WANT TO DO THAT AGAIN?
HIS CAMPAIGN IS CLEARLY ON LIFE
SUPPORT.
A FOURTH-PLACE FINISH IN IOWA, A
DISASTROUS FIFTH PLACE FINISH IN
NEW HAMPSHIRE, HE RAN OUT OF
TOWN, DID NOT EVEN SAY GOODBYE
TO HIS SUPPORTERS.
HE PHONED IT IN, HE FACE TIMED
IT.
BY THE WAY, NOW AHEAD OF
SOUTH CAROLINA, HAYES IS A
PART, A KEY PART OF THE
DEMOCRATIC COALITION OF BASE, IT
IS HIDING.
UNMITIGATED DISASTER.
HONESTLY, IT’S NOT REALLY
SHOCKING.
FOR MONTHS, HIS CAMPAIGN HAS
BEEN PLAGUED WITH SERIOUS
CORRUPTION ALLEGATIONS OUT OF
UKRAINE, CHINA, AND ELSEWHERE.
A FEW DAYS AGO, POLITICIAN WHAT
WOULD NEVER DO THIS?
CALLING A YOUNG FEMALE WATER, 21
YEARS OLD, AS SHE SAID SHE FELT
HUMILIATED, A LION, DOG
FACED PONY SOLDIER.
HELLO.
BEFORE THAT, HE CALLED ANOTHER
BOATER A DAMN LIAR AND ANOTHER
ONE FACT, CHALLENGE THEM TO A
PUSH OF COMPETITION.
HE CAN’T GET THAT TOGETHER.
HE’S BARELY COHERENT FOR A
LESSON, SOUTH CAROLINA, NO
EXCEPTION.
WE HAD THE VIDEO EVIDENCE.
LET’S GO TO THE VIDEOTAPE.
>> IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE
SPOKEN BUT WE NEED TO HEAR FROM
NEVADA AND SOUTH CAROLINA AND
SUPER TUESDAY DATES AND BEYOND.
>> Sean: WHAT YOU SELL MIXING
UP STATES, PRETTY MILD GAFFE BY
30330 STANDARDS.
WITH HIS CAMPAIGN ON LIFE
SUPPORT, LET’S TAKE ONE MORE
WALKED ON LITTLE MEMORY LANE,
SHALL WE?
TO SOME OF BIDEN’S FIND IT TO MY
FINEST MOMENT AS A PUBLIC FIGURE
IT’S GETTING WORSE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> [BLEEP].
>> HIS MOM LIVED IN LONG ISLAND
FOR TEN YEARS OR SO, GOD REST
HER SOUL -- WAY TO YOUR MOM IS
STILL ALIVE.
YOUR DAD PASSED.
GOD BLESS HER SOUL.
>> THE STATE SENATORS HERE.
CHUCK, STAND UP, CHUCK, LET THEM
SEE YOU.
OH, GOD LOVE YOU.
WHAT AM I TALKING ABOUT?
>> THE MAN WHO WILL BE THE NEXT
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES,
BARACK AMERICA.
>> DELAWARE, THE LARGEST GROWTH
IN POPULATION IS INDIAN
AMERICANS MOVING FROM INDIA.
YOU CANNOT GO TO A 7-ELEVEN OR A
DUNKIN’ DONUTS UNLESS YOU HAVE A
SLIGHT INDIAN ACCENT.
I’M NOT JOKING.
>> Sean: OH, THERE’S THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY FRONTRUNNER,
AND NOW, BY THE WAY, HIS
CAMPAIGN IS CIRCLING THE DRAIN.
BUT HE IS NOT GIVING UP HOPE.
JUST TODAY, BIDEN ROLLING OUT A
BRAND-NEW LOW-BUDGET ADD
CLAIMING HE IS JUST GETTING
STARTED.
FOURTH-PLACE, FIFTH-PLACE, LET’S
TRY FOR SIX.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE DON’T FEEL NO WAYS TIRED.
WE’VE COME TOO FAR FROM WHERE WE
STARTED.
NOBODY TOLD ME THE ROAD WOULD BE
EASY AND I DON’T BELIEVE YOU
BROUGHT ME THIS FAR TO STOP NOW.
YOU DON’T LIKE WHAT’S GOING ON
IN THIS COUNTRY, YOU ONLY HAVE
ONE THING TO DO.
WORK.
TOGETHER WE CAN AND WILL WIN.
LET’S TAKE BACK THIS COUNTRY
NOW!
>> Sean: THAT’S NOT PLAGIARISM
AGAIN, IS IT?
WHO DID IT BETTER, JOE OR
HILLARY?
ALL THESE QUID PRO QUO JOE CAN
TAKE SOME COMFORT IN KNOWING HE
WASN’T THE ONLY BIG LOSER IN
NEW HAMPSHIRE.
SYRIA LIAR,
FELLOW SOCIALIST
ELIZABETH WARREN ALSO HAD A VERY
POOR SHOWING.
KEEP IN MIND, NEW HAMPSHIRE
BORDERS HER HOME STATE OF
MASSACHUSETTS, WHERE MOST OF THE
POPULATION LIVES.
WARREN VIRTUALLY HAS NO PATH TO
VICTORY.
SHE IS SHIFTING HER LAST
REMAINING CAMPAIGN FUNDS TO MAKE
ONE LAST STAND, THIS TIME IN
NEVADA, AND TONIGHT, IT IS
UNCLEAR JUST WHO IS GOING TO
DROP OUT OF THE DEMOCRATIC RACE
NEXT.
THERE IS SOMETHING TO BET ON.
ONE THING IS CERTAIN.
SOCIALIST BERNIE SANDERS IS NOT
GOING ANYWHERE.
HE’S BUILDING A LARGE COALITION
OF RADICAL, DEDICATED DEMOCRATIC
VOTERS AND NOW WANT OF HIS TOP
ADVISORS IS EVEN CALLING FOR
MIKE BLOOMBERG TO DROP OUT OF TH
MIKE HAS GOT THIS GREAT CAMPAIGN
GOING.
HE PAYS FOR ADS, AND HIDES, AND
NO ONE EVER SEES HIM MARKETS TO
ASK HIM A QUESTION.
WOW FOR A GREAT WAY, SLICK MARKE
CAMPAIGN.
AFTER NEW VIDEO EMERGED THIS
WEEK SHOWING BLOOMBERG’S TRUE
FEELINGS ABOUT MINORITIES,
2013 -- THAT’S RIGHT.
BLOOMBERG SAYING, WHITE PEOPLE
WERE BEING STOPPED TOO MUCH BY
POLICE.
MINORITIES TOO LITTLE.
AND HE SAID IN 2015 BY THE ONLY
WAY TO PREVENT THIS CRIME WAS TO
THROW MINORITY KIDS -- POLICE,
THROW THEM UP AGAINST THE WALL
AND FRISK THEM.
BY THE WAY, THEN HE SAID, ALL --
HE PUT THE WORD ALL IN THERE --
HE PUT ALL OF THE POLICE AND
MINORITY NEIGHBORHOODS.
NOT SOME, ALL OF THEM IN
NEW YORK BECAUSE THAT IS WHERE
ALL THE CRIME IS.
REALLY?
I LIVE IN NEW YORK AND I CAN
TELL YOU THAT IS NOT TRUE.
DESPITE THESE DISTURBING
COMMENTS, BLOOMBERG, HE WILL
SPEND MONEY COME HE’S NOT GOING
ANYWHERE.
WE SENT OUR OWN LAWRENCE JONES
TO NEW YORK CITY TO SEE WHAT
MINIBIKES FORMER CONSTITUENTS
THINK ABOUT THEIR OWN MAYOR.
OF COURSE, THE BILLIONAIRE FROM
A REPUBLICAN IN NAME ONLY AS THE
DEMOCRATIC ESTABLISHMENTS PLAN
THE AFTER BIDEN’S IMPLOSION.
AS WE SPEAK, IT APPEARS THE
PANIC ESTABLISHMENT
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS EXPLORING
WAYS -- LOOKS LIKE THEY MAY WANT
TO BREAK THE ELECTION AGAIN
AGAINST BERNIE SANDERS.
MAYBE IN FAVOR OF BLOOMBERG OR
WHOEVER ELSE IS LEFT STANDING.
TRY AND BUY THE NOMINATION IN
BLOOMBERG’S CASE.
THAT WOULD INCLUDE NEW MEASURES
THAT COULD GIVE SUPERDELEGATES,
OAK, A BOAT ON THE FIRST BALLOT
THE RIGHT TO BLOCK TO BERNIE.
AT A CONVENTION.
WHATEVER HAPPENS IN THE COMING
WEEKS AND MONTHS, THE STATE OF
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY HAS NEVER
BEEN WORSE.
STILL, LET ME EMPHASIZE AGAIN,
ANYTHING CAN HAPPEN.
I TAKE NOTHING FOR GRANTED.